الولايات المتحده ليست في وضع يسمح لها
بتوجيه اصابع الاتهام الى الصين بشان
طبيعه علاقتها مع روسيا او طريقه تعاملها
مع الحرب في اوكرانيا هذا هو مفاد تصريح
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه الولايات المتحده
وليست الصين من ترسل الاسلحه الى ساحه
المعركه نهج الصين تجاه قضيه اوكرانيا
لهدف واحد وهو الحث على السلام وتعزيز
المحادثات اللهجه الصينيه الجافه تاتي بعد
تحذير جديد اطلقه وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
قال انه اعلم نظيره الصيني عندما التقاه
على هامشي مؤتمر ميونخ بالقلق الامريكي من
ان تكون في قول الاستعداد لمنح موسكو
اسلحه وذخائر
راينا شركات صينيه تقدم دعما غير فتاك
لروسيا كي تستخدمه في اوكرانيا ما يقلقنا
حسب المعلومات المتوفره لدينا ان الصينيين
يخططون الان لتقديم دعم فتاك وقد اوضحنا
ان هذه المشكله خطيره وتؤثر على علاقاتنا
دخول الصين على خط الحرب في اوكرانيا
كابوس بالنسبه الى الغرب رئيس الدبلوماسيه
الاوروبيه قال ايضا انه حذر مسؤول
الخارجيه الصينيه من مغبه تزويد الصين
لروسيا بالسلاح سيكون ذلك بمثابه خط احمر
في علاقتنا اخبرني السيد
انهم لن يفعلوا ذلك ولا يخططون للقيام به
لكننا سنبقى يقظين
ليس سرا انا بكين قدم دعما دبلوماسيا
لموسكو في المحافل الدوليه امتنعت عن
ادانه الحرب ضد اوكرانيا اوصفها بالغزو
وبعد فرض الغرب على موسكو اشد العقوبات في
التاريخ الحديث اتجه الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين نحو اسيا تحديدا الى الصين لتعزيز
شركات الاقتصاديه وزياره كبير
الدبلوماسيين الصينيين الى موسكو اعطيت
عنوانا عريضا هو ايجاد تسويه سلميه في
اوكرانيا